le deuxième forum de l'intelligence
artificielle s'est déroulée au château
de rambouillet objectif parler des
solutions de l'intelligence artificielle
au profit des territoires avec des
secteurs privilégiés la santé la
sécurité les transports
un plan qui a doté d'un milliard et demi
d'euros
l'objectif de l'état c'est de fédérer
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'intelligence
artificielle l'intérêt de rambouillet
c'est tout d'abord de montrer ce que
nous défendons avec valérie pécresse est
ce qu'elle a à coeur de défendre que la
région et polycentrique tout ne se passe
pas à paris vous avez en fait une région
qui est très diverse parler des
solutions de l'intelligence artificielle
au profit du territoire c'est la raison
de la venue de ce jeune chef
d'entreprise issu de la recherche de
l'institut yvelinois bd comme on vient
pour présenter donc nos solutions en
fait nos outils en termes d'intelligence
artificielle qui sont ici maintenant de
cinq ans de recherches et qui vise en
fait à montrer la connaissance de la
mobilité sur les territoires dont l
usage des territoires pour les
territoires un des thèmes de ces 2e
forum européen de l'intelligence
artificielle les territoires ruraux
intelligent ce quarantenaire installé à
rambouillet le fondateur d'un site
internet
on est présent sur plus de 37 pays avec
vraiment une note d'une identité pièce
agricole et matin et maintenant matériel
agricole sur le web
donc il ya ça fait déjà quelques années
que qu'on y est
objectif pour les collectivités attirer
ces entreprises sur leur territoire pour
développer le secteur de l'intelligence
artificielle